Mo you were in 19 episodes of Parks and
Recreation did you realize at 19. I know
what do you remember of the casting
process what do you remember about
joining Parks and Rec oh absolutely
remember the the casting of it
um they you know they wanted this uh
newscastery cable access lady not really
good very green so I really tried to
just play it as real as possible because
you know single camera was fairly new
then so that whole style coming away
from sitcom and everything was like dial
it just dial it way way down and I just
you know just did my I just did very
real yeah
um
and then of course we see where it went
from there yeah yeah but it's very
grounded I actually really do enjoy
going back and seeing the evolution of
Joan and when you do go back and and I
still regardless of how
um extreme let's just say that Joan
became how outlandish
I always every single time I would do an
episode I really did try to remember
that very first episode and some of the
things that I was telling myself about
not being very very slick with the
speaking when it comes to actually doing
her show just to you know kind of skip
up a little bit while still you know
trying to be professional just making it
having a bit of That Awkward in there
but I I totally
remember the audition tiny room was it
was it with the boys
just for the record she is now also yeah
naked uh from the bottom it becomes me
yeah
um who was in the room with the boys
yeah it was just you know in and out as
it is but once you join the show I feel
like your character and you made this
indelible Mark in especially once you
and Amy would be in a scene together I
think there's a special energy I think
this is what happened and I'm grateful
for it um as I am with any job that has
me do this is I I keep going until they
yell cut you know and uh it's improv is
my BFF and I think from there you know
part of it was just Moe Collins playing
on set but stuff comes out and they
start to see
just potential of of writing and I I
feel like that is where the writer sort
of went
she's game right like she's a player
she's a game and I do that on any job I
go to whether they want me to or not but
um but if they're smart they see that
they do and they know to let it ride but
look one time I specifically remember
uh Amy Poehler saying Moe's here just
keep the camera rolling okay now is
there a better compliment than that no
there's not and it's also like
Woman to Woman yeah it's
um such a beautiful thing to have a
contemporary you know be so supportive
that's why Parks and Rec was so great
the captain of the ship had no ego
exactly 100 that gave me a lot of
confidence being a guest there you know
it was I'd always felt like sort of a
cousin to the family right which was
really fun because I they had an
expectation when I would show up that I
would maybe
deliver some extra treats I think people
like Mo I think people like Ben Schwartz
they just knew okay we have our script
and we have a base
let him do their thing yeah the plot out
we need let's get the base done and then
to let them do what they do and look
what they do I mean Joan calamazo is
mining for gold it's you know Parks and
Rec the script already was gold yeah but
on any comedy what you do want to do
is mine for more gold while you're while
you're there and that's why you get
funny people to do comedy yeah I still
maintain that funny people okay let me
write this down one second
it's great when funny people don't put
that in pencil not pen I'm not sure
Parks and Rec I think our set was famous
for fun runs where after we've recorded
the scene that we need then we do a Fun
Run and just for the actors just to have
fun to improv as much as you want as
long as you get a general sense of the
scene as needed yep still have fun
because you never know what gold would
come and I feel like when you are on set
especially when you'd be with Amy as
well both people with huge improv
backgrounds yeah there must have been
this element of the Fun Run is happening
throughout you know that each of you
trust each other right it's the trust it
is it's the trust you know and I
obviously know they're good for it we
cut we're Cut From the Same Cloth yeah
and what you said which is so 100 on Amy
Poehler has has no ego right she wants
what's best for the show yeah and so she
knew who you she knows what you do she
knows what you bring and so for her
Let Her Go Let Her Go and it's beyond
that it's the support goes to where Amy
actually wanted me to shine she didn't
want me to just do well for her show she
wanted me to shine she wanted to shine a
light on me you know and that's what
really good people do yes you know is is
you you shine a light you know that's
why you want your own light to shine
because that light is shining onto
somebody else and that's what Amy is
really good at and so am I yeah
100 it keeps coming out but it's just
you're saying exactly how I feel yeah
that's how Amy was for Seven Seasons
yeah it was never about Amy uh and that
you know as Moe and I we have been on a
lot of shows over the years we've seen a
lot of things over the years and a lot
of times your leads
are what they are and funny goes to them
and you can lose funny because it's
going to go to the lead that was never
the case not with Amy not with anybody
on Parks but I just I I love that you
saw that too I just oh absolutely and
you know Amy's one of your biggest fans
and I'm one of hers too because it's you
know like I say it's like looking at
people that and watching her career and
now granted they went in different
directions
but uh you know um which by the way when
you leave make sure you clean the table
I just gotta make sure you get all this
stuff all the garbage out but I do
understand how she started and how I
started and I know what it all feels
like and and that was really keeping an
eye on Ensemble too like I come from
Dudley Riggs Brave New Workshop in
Minneapolis and the it really was about
Ensemble you know uh not about the
individual it's about what can the
Ensemble accomplish together and we make
each other many interviews have asked me
over the years oh would you love your
own show like you know no no no it is an
ensemble that always the cheers
Carol Burnett that's the dream and and I
had it for seven years because Parks was
an ensemble I I couldn't agree more I
just yeah it's all about the group
effort and everyone's supporting each
other yeah and not every bit works not
everything whatever but you're all there
for each other and when it works it can
just explode but it's not even such a
bad thing to fail together sure of
course you know like I mean I go back to
Mad TV days for that you know there were
some things that failed and failed right
in front of the audience and Brilliant
yeah brilliant but when we failed like
that we're like all right let's do
another take and then the Improv comes
in and Ensemble gathers together and
boom you've got gold like you just find
stuff like the process of Comedy is just
ah
it was so good isn't it
good I just sunk in a little bit because
it truly is like just pure
chocolate yeah it's a treat chocolate is
really good chocolate is yeah and what
but when it when it all comes together
that feeling is like no other images you
know it's it's why people keep golfing I
know this is a crazy I'm jumping off the
bridge here but you know you golf
because you get that one good shot
during the 18 holes that keeps you
coming back that's what comedy is you
get that one moment you're like oh I do
love that it's a drug I guess I think it
might be a bit of a drug and you need to
you're constantly searching for that and
if you're lucky you end up with a group
of people you get it a lot I know a
whole lot it's the luckiest place to be